Welcome to the first lecture
of this class.
You may be used to having a
first lecture devoted to
general comments and motivating
examples.
This one will be different.
We will dive into the heart
of the subject right away.
In fact, today we will
accomplish a lot.
By the end of this lecture, you
will know about all of the
elements of a probabilistic
model.
A probabilistic model is a
quantitative description of a
situation, a phenomenon,
or an experiment
whose outcome is uncertain.
Putting together such a model
involves two key steps.
First, we need to describe the
possible outcomes of the
experiment.
This is done by specifying
a so-called sample space.
And then, we specify a
probability law, which assigns
probabilities to outcomes or
to collections of outcomes.
The probability law tells us,
for example, whether one
outcome is much more likely
than some other outcome.
Probabilities have to satisfy
certain basic properties in
order to be meaningful.
These are the axioms of
probability theory.
For example probabilities
cannot be negative.
Interestingly, there will be
very few axioms, but they are
powerful, and we will see
that they have lots of
consequences.
We will see that they imply
many other properties that
were not part of the axioms.
We will then go through a couple
of very simple examples
involving models with
either discrete
or continuous outcomes.
As you will be seeing many times
in this class, discrete
models are conceptually
much easier.
Continuous models involve some
more sophisticated concepts,
and we will point out some of
the subtle issues that arise.
And finally, we will talk a
little bit about the big
picture, about the role of
probability theory, and its
relation with the real world.